there'd be nothing unusual about the
number of babies who died in the
neonatal unit of the Countess of Chester
Hospital until January 2015 but over the
next 18 months staff saw a significant
increase in the number of babies dying
or suffering serious collapse the reason
prosecutors say is that a poisoner was
at work
Lucy letby was a neonatal nurse at the
hospital she was also prosecuted say the
common denominator in all of the
inexplicable collapses and deaths that
she murdered seven babies and attempted
to murder 10 others some of the victims
were brother and sister some were twins
she was brought to court to hear the
jury told that hospital officials
couldn't understand why babies who'd not
been unstable suddenly deteriorated
when police were called in they found
that someone in the neonatal unit had
poisoned two babies with insulin the
prosecution says this was no accident
that the babies were deliberately
poisoned
opening the prosecution case Nicholas
Johnson KC told the jury the collapse
and deaths of the 17 children named in
the indictment were not naturally
occurring tragedies they were the work
of the woman in the dock who was the
constant malevolent presence when things
took a turn for the worse
the jury was shown what's called a
nurse's present chart recording all of
the staff who were working in the
neonatal unit listed were the names of
the 17 babies involved in this case and
the times it's alleged they were
attacked an X next to the name of all of
the nurses who were working only one the
prosecution say was present on All
Occasions and that was Lucy letby Mr
Johnson told the jury sometimes Lucy
letby tried to kill the same baby more
than once sometimes a baby she succeeded
in killing she didn't manage to kill the
first time she tried or even the second
time and in one case even the third time
Lucy letby's parents were in court to
hear the case against her so two family
members of some of her alleged child
victims a court order prevents the
reporting of anything that could
identify the babies or their parents
the court heard Lucy letby took an
unusual interest in the families of some
of the babies who died she'd search for
them online and tracked one on Facebook
she denies all 22 counts of murder and
attempted murder and the trial continues
Greg Milam Sky News Manchester